[Music]
if i ask a direct question as simple as
i go to the store tonight just make me
feel like i'm crazy for asking a
question
for whatever reason you ask that one
question and he feels a certain way but
the response is she's making me feel
this way so i've got to turn this back
around on her
[Music]
what's up what's up
this is the john delony show the dr john
deloney show
probably would help if i knew what this
show was called we talk about mental
health relationships
nobody in the world calls me dr
john except for people who call the show
my friends call me
words that i won't repeat here same with
my wife
she calls me john deloney sometimes
kelly you call me mean things
not to your face that's a that's true
that's true but sometimes they forward
me the emails and i'm like huh dang
um
hey somebody asked i'm just teasing this
we'll have conversations later somebody
asked hey i haven't heard from james in
a while just put a pin in that listeners
put a pin in it
big james news coming up there's not
anything i just love doing that
uh big james news he's like five foot
four there is no big james news at all
actually
unless he plugs in his fenders and
starts jangling his little heart
whatever i'm not going to be mean to him
i haven't seen him i wonder james isn't
here
why isn't he here why isn't he here why
does he always make these hostile work
like complaints whatever hey if you want
to be on this show give me a
six nine call
three two nine one it's one eight four
four six nine three thirty two ninety
one and yes i got it so the internets
don't get all mad james is like one of
my closest buddies he's awesome he's a
friend so
don't send me mean cards and letters all
right let's go to ronda help help me
rhonda in oklahoma city what's up rhonda
hi dr john how are you
i'm rocking on south breaking down all
right fantastic
um things going okay doing all right
doing all right very cool so what's up
well i i watched a show a while back
looking at gas lighting in a movie
tangled
my husband and i have been married over
10 years now and he is an expert
gaslighter and i've been through
counseling
and my husband and i have worked through
a lot of things and while it's not as
personal feeling as it once was the
gaslighting is still common
i'd like your advice on what to do when
it is happening hmm
okay so okay this is um some
behind the curtain stuff
um whenever
they came the team came and said hey we
want you to do some of these react
videos i was like dude no one's gonna
watch this
and so you're telling me that you
watched the tangled one
i did okay and
you recognized oh man this is us this is
me this is my husband
yeah give me an example uh that you make
you just made the whole team feel good
and you make me feel i have to say i was
wrong so i said no one's gonna watch
this i was wrong
um that's my one time i'll say that for
2022. so
tell me what it looks like give me an
example or two of your husband
gaslighting you as an expert
um yes as an expert um
well um one thing is just if i ask a
direct question it could be something as
simple as
i go to the store tonight he'll
you know ask me like what do you mean go
to the store or
um just make me feel like i'm crazy for
asking a question
something else might be
if i'm
um going out with a family member or
friend you know he'll make some comment
like
um well what's she gonna wear tonight or
somehow implying that it's it's
inappropriate
um
so does it have to do with is he just
poking at you is he belittling you or is
it his way of saying i don't want you to
go but he doesn't have the courage to
state his needs out loud so he just he
constantly makes you feel a little bit
off-kilter and a little bit nuts
i think it's that last one okay
okay
um or when you say hey are you gonna go
to store tonight is that you asking him
somewhat passively
hey i need some help around here could
you run to the store for me or does he
have keys in hand he's walking out the
door and you just ask hey where are you
going
no he's actually super helpful and it's
more
um i think he puts pressure on himself
and so sometimes he's reading something
into it that's probably not there
oh like you might be accusing him or
uh yeah i think he might see it that way
so
again i'm gonna
grossly over generalize this
when it comes to men and women but
many folks especially men don't know the
language of feelings
what i mean by that is
something happens somebody asks them a
question they experience a thing
somebody asks them hey will you help me
with something and they don't want to do
it they can't do it um they don't have
time to do it and so they feel
uncomfortable either they feel
uncomfortable because they can't meet
somebody's needs they can't they don't
know how to do something and they feel
less than whatever the thing is they
don't they're not well-versed in the
language of feelings
and so
this thing happens to their body and
they begin to look externally is just
somebody else's fault
right
and that's where you
come in
for whatever reason you ask that one
question and he
feels a certain way doesn't know how to
look in the mirror and say these are my
feelings happening to my body about my
issues it's nothing to do with my wife
and but it respo the response is
she's making me feel this way so i've
got to turn this back around on her does
that sound right
it sounds exactly right
okay
what do you do what have you tried in
the past that has worked or hasn't
worked
um i've tried a lot of things some have
worked and some haven't worked um
definitely trying the same thing does
not work
right um
some things that work better than others
is if i you know sometimes i'll just
simply ignore it and just kind of move
on
and i feel like that can sometimes build
up over time though if it's not
addressed
um
sometimes if it feels more intense i'll
just
exit
um so let me just
point this out to everybody listening
avoidance is
unless you're avoiding a bullet right
you're avoiding physical harm
relational avoidance
almost
never helps
yeah right it almost sometimes it takes
it's not the right moment like if
somebody's really fired up this isn't
the moment to have a deep conversation
but not circling back and avoiding it
long term is never a good idea right um
so you've tried that doesn't work what
else
um probably some of the best success is
if i follow up with a question like what
makes you think that or what makes you
ask that sometimes he'll be more open to
it
um
often he'll he'll just and it's in it's
like you mentioned certain topics are
more sensitive than others and so it's
kind of those landmine topics that he
just
really puts up a big wall
so i want to flip the gaslighting
conversation around for you okay
less about how you can deal with him
and more about you
okay
so here's the path forward i think when
it comes to gaslighting
you get very very clear
about your worth
you get very very clear about
i'm worth more than being talked to like
this
or i'm not crazy
stop talking to me like i'm crazy
my request for you i'm your wife i need
some help with fill in the blank
um become very clear about what you like
and what you don't like
the nerd word is these are just needs
here's what i need i need you to not
come home and try to grope me when
you're covered up in oil or whatever
from changing that like like i don't
need that right or i need you to yeah
that sounded kind of weird i was
thinking about car oil not like um
been in the booth was started laughing
i'm not that kind of oil it's not
talking about
um
but i need you to help with the dishes i
need you to help right so what what do
you like what do you not like
and then also this is important and this
gets left out of the uh gaslighting
conversation a lot
you have to learn to be comfortable
with saying i was wrong
i messed up taking ownership of the
times you do like
you know withhold or you're angry or you
snap it like whatever you fly off the
handle coming back and saying nope
that's not gaslighting i just i was mean
i'm sorry right
um
and then you have to get over this idea
that it's your responsibility to make
him feel good about himself
is that fair
yes that's fair
and so
then you land there
um
you said things are getting a little bit
better
yes tell me what that means
um so there's some things um one of the
big issues for me was
um i really wanted kids and um
and quite frankly that one i just had to
um
decide you know if i could live with him
without kids and and i did so
i think that has calmed things down a
little bit because he feels more secure
that i've made that decision can we can
we pause right there
yes have you grieved that
i'm in the process okay okay
yeah um if you don't if you just make a
logical mathematical decision
that resentment will build up over time
and will become highly explosive
or worse it becomes toxic right so
explosive is we have this big blowout
somebody cheats on somebody it's a big
explosion
toxic is we just slow drip
dis dislike and disgust and get away
from me and you're gross and ugh and you
see him make a face and you interpret
that negatively and he interprets your
words right it just poisons everything
if you don't grieve it and say i wanted
kids and i had a picture of our live
having kids and it's not gonna happen
and i'm choosing to stay in a
relationship where it's not gonna happen
and so ultimately the choice is mine and
i'm making it and i'm gonna grieve it
and then we're going to move does that
make sense so make sure that you spend
time
changing that picture for yourself okay
good
okay so
you're dealing with that in process
right
okay does he know that
all he's quote unquote getting what he
wants he didn't want kids did you know
that going in
you know
okay yeah no we had talked about before
and it changed so that was one of the
hard things yeah
okay
does he have a language for i made a
choice that is
um
an existential
pain for my wife
i don't think so i i think it's um
it's just a lot of fear okay
he's gotta take ownership of that
doesn't mean it was the wrong choice for
y'all doesn't mean he's a bad guy
but he has to own i made a choice
that hurt my wife and her soul
and she chose to feel that hurt and stay
with me anyway but i did i i made a
decision that
was a what caused my wife to hurt he's
got to own that otherwise the deflection
mechanism is gaslighting
yeah right that's the only way to keep
an arm's length from knowing i hurt
somebody is just to make them feel nuts
all the time
yeah a lot of sense okay
um
have you gotten good about being very
clear
i am getting better okay all right good
it is taking practice um so yes
um one one thing that came up somewhat
recently is
um the resentment thing and i had a hard
time
conveying that i was frustrated
with the decision um without him
recognizing how big of a decision it was
and without it him going straight to
well you can divorce me or you can do
these kind of things and i don't want to
go there but
actually
um i read that clause reals book
and um
and
just came to him and said i feel like
i am going to resent you at some point
if you don't work out this stuff right
and um
and still to be determined how much
that's sunk in or not yeah so so can i
ask you this
the way you just phrased that i think is
really
important i think i'm gonna resent you
if you don't do this stuff
and the way you said
it's still to be determined tells me
he's not doing the stuff
and so the question i have for you is
does this ultimately end with you
leaving
or does this ultimately end with you
leaving psychologically but staying
physically
and just that's why i'm
yeah that's what i'm afraid of
but it's a fear that you can control
right
and so i'm scared of a lion
you have the choice to say i'm gonna do
the hard work and set this thing down
or i'm gonna leave
it's the middle ground that's gonna make
you insane
and quite frankly you're gonna poison a
guy who just said here's what i need i
need to not have kids
and i'm not letting him off the hook if
he was on the phone by the way we'd be
having this opposite conversation here
um ultimately this lands on you being
able to say your needs out loud
do not talk to me like that
i'm not accusing you of anything if you
feel like i'm accusing you i need you to
ask that question
i need you to go to the store for me
instead of were you going to the store
because if you're going i need you to
pick up some things so that's kind of
passive right i want you to become very
affirmative and i love the word you just
use practice this is probably something
you've never done before huh
yeah it's been practice yes good for you
good for you
um tell me a success you're having
um one thing that we've worked out is um
especially when we first got into
marriage um we were very you know
stereotypical roles and and
i was
doing the cooking and that kind of stuff
and it just
we kept hitting a wall with it because
he wouldn't like it or whatever and so
he has taken over the cooking and i do
the dishes and it really works well it's
a good partnership there
yes outstanding excellent excellent so
you all are practicing changing your
behaviors right not just thinking
through things but you are doing
different things
great that's awesome
and
it's okay if y'all can develop this
relationship i mean this this
communication pattern which i love
in our house let's say and i'll just use
my kids for example
they don't have permission in the house
to say mom this dinner's gross
because that's disrespectful and rude
they can say
i tried it and i don't care for it
that's factual that's fair they just
they're allowed to say that
there's a kind way to say things there's
a difference when you make food all day
and then somebody sits down it's like
this is gross
versus
um thank you so much for this dinner not
my not i let's go back to the burgers
let's do some right so there's like
there's a kind way to say things moving
forward
and calling one another to a more
dignified respectful way of interacting
with each other i think it's just
something you practice right especially
if you've never seen it before
right well that's awesome it sounds like
you're on the right track
hopefully
i want you to circle back to the very
beginning here
i want you to spend some time
writing down what you're worth
writing down very specifically what are
your needs what do you need from him
write down very specifically
how he broke your heart when it came to
kids
how it hurts
and it may be that one day with you and
a counselor and him you write him a
letter and say i need you to feel this
and you read it
and in that letter it talks about how
much it hurts and how you had plans you
had you were gonna go to graduations you
couldn't wait to
stand by your daughter while she got
married to some knucklehead right you
had these pictures in these plans and
they're not gonna happen
and there's something about reading that
out loud and then saying but i'm staying
anyway and so now we're gonna build
something totally new we gotta there's
no picture in the frame we gotta build a
whole new picture and live into it and
then that's gonna be your life's
adventure moving forward but you've
gotta stop in the grief section you've
gotta sit there and grieve this thing
gotta grieve it and then we're gonna
move on and then and then the more you
hang on to it that becomes an issue with
you
if you choose to
forgive
grieve and start acting start behaving
start moving in different directions you
can't circle back on and be like oh well
because it's done it's done and then he
becomes the victim there right so we're
gonna work together on this deal
good for you for challenging him for
saying no more gaslighting in my house
now i want you to go one step deeper and
decide
i've got value and i've got worth
and i
am going to ask the people who are in
relationship with me and my home to
acknowledge that value and i'm going to
acknowledge theirs we'll be right back
hey what's up daloni here i've got a
word from our sponsor better help i'm
always getting calls about burnout what
it is what to do about it and just how
to live feeling this way
burnout is when your body has enough and
it says i'm out i'm done it's that deep
feeling of exhaustion after a long
period of being overworked and
overstressed and just fried and most of
us associate burnout with work but
burnout can happen at any area of our
lives and it can cause a lack of
motivation irritability fatigue or
randomly crying at some random song on
the radio or when somebody looks at you
the wrong way and that's why i love my
friends at betterhelp betterhelp online
therapy exists to give you the chance to
invest in your healing better help is
customized online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with you and your therapist you never
have to even see anyone on camera if you
don't want to it's more affordable than
in-person therapy plus you can be
matched with the therapist in under 48
hours and today our listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
that's betterhelphelp.com
all right we're back hey before we go to
the next call this is very cool
the
988
suicide prevention hotline launches
nationwide
launches nationwide
now two quick things number one
i think the idea
that we have a culture that needs
hotlines
is a should be ringing an alarm bell for
us
the data tells us that most people don't
have somebody to call at 2 am and say i
need help
it's our responsibility
as adults it's our responsibility as
parents it's our responsibility as
community members
to stop that trend directly in its
tracks
short like the short story is we have to
make friends i've got to have people
that i invite into my life on a regular
basis that i can do life with right but
we don't have that right now
number two
if you are whining and complaining about
the suicide prevention hotline are there
gonna be enough callers are there gonna
be enough people on the phone shut up
stop
there's so much complaining when
somebody wants to do something different
and new to crete to help people in their
communities
and we shut down so much stuff
because of regulations and red tape and
yeah but what about
i need a generation of people that will
just start trying to help and then we
will figure it out as we go
and so i'm a huge fan of the 988 suicide
prevention hotline mainly because most
of these calls either nobody makes a
call or it goes to 9-1-1
and you've got people those dispatchers
trying to handle a bunch of different
stuff
this is incredible
here's what it says people experiencing
a mental health crisis can now call or
text a three-digit number 988
call or text
the new number connects the caller to a
certified crisis center in the area
where the call is placed the hotline is
made up of a network of 200 local crisis
centers around the country
the number is expected to be easier to
remember in times of crisis than the 10
digit 800 number that the national
suicide prevention lifeline has
currently
and it's going to help um streamline
mental health responses so people can
get the urgent help they need much
faster than 9-1-1 if you call 9-1-1
um again that's the only call you make
make that call but it goes from a
dispatcher to police officers who then
have to reach out to the mental health
there's some gaps there
this um gets you right to a mental
health professional which is amazing
nine eight eight
and
even cooler if you remember a few weeks
ago we had an extraordinary young man a
veteran on on the um on the show talking
about his challenges with suicide
if you dial 988 and then press one
nine eight eight and then press one
it's going to be a direct veterans
crisis line
if you're concerned about a veteran if
you are a veteran and you're struggling
with suicide with hurting yourself with
purposelessness you're scared
988 and then press one
veterans can still contact any of the uh
the old um vcl numbers the veteran
veterans crisis line numbers all those
things are still going to be there
but this is a
express pass 988
press one right nine eight eight one so
here's the deal y'all heard me say this
a million times i'll say a million times
more
if you are gonna hurt yourself
call somebody
if the thought enters your head
people would be better off without me
around you're wrong
i don't know you and i don't know your
situation but i know that you're wrong
if you know if somebody's hurting call
and they've just made it easier 988 and
if you're lonely if you're disconnected
please
reach out and start the arduous awkward
weird process of making friends
especially as an adult it's hard it's
awful it's weird it's the worst and we
got to
we
have to
988 suicide prevention hotline good for
us let's make this thing work and as
there's bumps along the way and gaps in
coverage and we got to figure out these
local crisis centers and all that kind
of stuff let's be champions of how we
can make this thing better not whiners
and complainers in the media cool deal
awesome all right let's go to lucas in
twin falls what's up lucas
hey dr john how's it going man good good
good good what's up
uh hey yeah so um i'm calling you
because uh i'd like to uh get some
advice from you on how i can help my
parents get out of a very unhealthy
living situation with my older brother
uh who's uh 31 years old
um
yeah
yeah so and uh and um i'll start off you
know this has been something that uh
essentially transpired for the past uh
10 to 12 years um uh it all started uh
well
when my older brother got into uh pretty
bad legal trouble when i was in
high school he's been in and out of jail
in and out of
treatment centers and
you know he's still living
at home and so
essentially uh i've been struggling with
you know seeing my parents uh you know
letting him stay
at home without having any boundaries uh
while basically being
a very bipolar addict and uh things are
just super super volatile
uh with them there right now
um
why is this come up now does something
happen or have you suddenly just worried
about them or
have you tried things why why now
yeah yeah so so um basically i feel like
so
i feel like my relationship with my
parents is uh put is potentially uh
on a thin line just because i've just
been super frustrated uh with them just
um allowing my brother to you know
live at home and uh basically um ruin
their life you know uh my parents are
both in their 60s right now on and uh
you know i feel like at this point you
can only give someone uh
so many chances um uh just to give you
some more details uh my brother um
he is sick he is uh
a struggling addict um he's done pretty
much everything under the sun he's also
clinically bipolar so i just when you
mix narcotics along with uh uh bipolar
disorder uh it's not a good thing and um
in in my recent conversations with my
family um you know i feel like my
parents are honestly just scared of
retaliation uh from him if they try to
kick him out it's
actually not that
i'm gonna um be super truthful with you
okay
okay
your parents are getting something out
of this relationship
whether toxic whether sideways whether
what
this is feeding something for them
whether they feel some kind of guilt
over the bipolar stuff or if there's
stuff from y'all's childhood that they
are trying to
quote unquote make up for or live into
or they're blaming themselves whatever
it is
they are getting something out of this
relationship
and maybe that it is
safety and security because they're
scared he's going to go do something if
they kick it all that to say
it's gonna be hard for you to hear
none of this is your business
what your business is is what you are
willing to tolerate relationally with
the people that you love and this is
going to be hard to hear but you have
been clear with your parents
that your brother needs professional
help and that he's probably draining
them financially he's probably has
seasons when he's not safe to be around
and they are choosing him over your
boundaries
and that leaves you to decide what you
are going to do inside of your
boundaries
so the hard answer here is there's
really nothing you can do for them
you can love them you can be kind you
can have a one more hard final with
gusto conversation
but at the end of the day they're 60
something year old adults who are making
a choice on a daily basis to live a life
for some reason
and the question is not how can i get
these 60 something year olds to change
you're not going to
you have to figure out how to be well
inside of this context and for most of
us
well in this side of context is
i'm i'm gonna go make other choices so i
can be well
you all are making your choices behavior
is a language they're choosing him
over themselves and over you
that make sense
yeah yeah no it does it's harsh it's a
harsh way to say it i know
i know
um yeah
and here's the deal they might be
helping him with a roof that's a huge
help for an addict that's a huge help
for someone struggling with mental
health challenges but another huge help
is
high accountability and responsibility
right well and see and that's so because
first of all i totally agree with what
you said and i do
appreciate it but that's the piece
that's missing is that um there's zero
accountability there and uh you know
from what i've seen over the years and
what i've talked about with your friends
and outside family members is that um
they think they're helping him but it's
really just enabling right lucas lucas
lucas yeah you got to walk away
you you have you have diagnosed your
brother you've diagnosed the problem
with your parents you've diagnosed the
relational issues and what you're doing
is you're churning energy on a situation
you cannot control
it's it's uh you you probably have a
friend
who all they do all day long is watch
political news
and they come up with these crazy
theories about trade deficits and oil
prices it's because of this
literally they can control nothing
they're wasting their day they're
absolutely wasting their day you can
look at the gas pump and say man that's
terrible i'm gonna have to adjust my
budget i'm gonna have to adjust what i
buy at the store i'm gonna have to
adjust how much i drive or carpooling
that will help
but me just sitting on youtube all day
trying to come up with solutions for
problems that see what i'm saying like
it becomes this futile spinning and
spinning and spinning
and that's where you are man
and what it's doing at the end of the
day it's an affirmative choice to take
joy and beauty and peace out of your
life trying to solve another problem
you're gonna have to grieve it it's
gonna suck
right but you haven't dropped your
shoulders and just said this is the way
this is this is how my parents are
choosing to live
and when you know you're right when you
do that
it's gonna hurt man
because you're gonna miss your parents
you're gonna miss your brother
and then you're gonna have to do the
hard work of seeking to not spend spin
your wheels trying to solve a problem
you can't solve but in seeking joy and
finding peace and finding laughter and
finding community and finding friends to
meet some of those needs that you hope
that your parents would meet but they're
not meeting them because they're too
hung up on their other situation yeah
okay so then so
that said what's your advice on um
setting boundaries within the
relationship with my parents and then
you know
deciding whether or not i want to
go go back home for the holidays and all
that because great as as you know you
know when
when you have um
yes when you have a private little son
in your family you know that tends to be
the topic of most of the conversations
yeah you know
it's already hard enough for uh
people but you know when you have
something like this there's just that
other looming elephant um in in the room
so what's your advice on
you know
setting boundaries for myself for my own
mental sanity and and um mental health
by the way um i actually started going
to therapy for
many reasons last year but uh this was
actually one of them was just kind of
coping with this
whole thing good for you for taking
affirmative steps um ultimately it's
this
you deciding
forget the consequences
decide what you're worth
and decide your value and decide what
you'll tolerate and what you won't
and it may come down to a conversation
like this
i love you mom and dad with all my heart
i can no longer be a participant in a
relationship where i'm watching somebody
hurt my parents over and over and over
and i will not talk about my brother
anymore
and so
if he's gonna be there during
thanksgiving or christmas
i'm gonna choose to not go
and so you're not doing ultimatums
you're not threatening
you are making grown-up choices with
your grown-up finances and your grown-up
choice-making abilities
they can then make grown-up choices on
their own
on whether we're going to have to ask
brother to leave
because we want lucas to come home
or we're going to talk bad about lucas
and make him feel guilty and make him
feel really bad for have for not caring
about his brother and for leaving his
parents high and dr that's their
grown-up choices to make how they
respond you cannot control that
and the more you hem in your needs
to try to make somebody else feel less
awkward
the
the the further from an authentic core
you get
the crazier you'll feel and most of us
feel crazy by getting pissed off we get
angry
yeah right and then we get angry we
start trying to blame and solve and
that's a whole cat look at our culture
that's us right
yeah yeah no no i mean you're right and
um yeah or telling your brother
i will not come to mom and dad's house
if you're still there
it's time for you to check into a rehab
facility and it's time for you to get
clean and if you're not great i am going
to choose to not be a part of this
dysfunction
and when you hang up the phone you may
have dude you may have a hole in your
gut
you may weep for hours
and the follow-up phone calls and texts
and letters may be caustic and mean you
may have to get to where you block your
parents from texting you
because you're going to send these long
talk to text texts right that are so
dramatic and so long
i cannot control
the response of other adults to my needs
and you might have to do the really hard
work of finding a new gang to do
thanksgiving with or a new gang to do
christmas with
and it might be the first peaceful
holiday season you've had in a long long
time
yeah yeah well i can say so i've i've
been married for a little over three
years and uh once i got married it's
basically been holidays i've been with
uh with my uh in-laws and it's been a
lot better there you go you know you
have a new you have a new picture right
you have another picture oh family can
look like this i thought it just looked
like that yeah this could look way
different right and that's fantastic
that's wonderful
i want you to mourn this like
trying to think
somewhere inside
there is a picture you had
of when you have your first little one
and or of the
how your parents were gonna welcome in
your wife and we're gonna hug hug hug
hug hug and it's gonna be this big
dramatic thing and they were gonna be
best friends and
your brother was gonna clean up
and at some point you have to have a you
have to grieve it you have to have a
funeral if you will
for that picture it's not gonna happen
or at least it's not gonna happen
anytime soon
yeah and once we do that then we can
begin to deal with reality which is
probably not gonna do christmas and
holidays there not a safe place for me
and my family
and that's awful i hate that
maybe one day two years later five years
later six years later
mom and dad make some pretty dramatic
changes brother gets clean they decide
to hold him accountable they decide well
we're gonna have nothing right
this might mean you're out of the will
or you're not gonna be
get uh inheritance what
great man these are about you this is
about you being well and living a
peaceful joyful life you see what i'm
saying
yeah ultimately sure it's about
reclaiming control
that you've outsourced to them
because you're waiting for them to make
the quote-unquote right choices and
decisions so that you can feel better
and that's never going to work that way
yeah no number one you're right um i
hate that man i feel like i'm like
though like i feel like it's like hey
here's a balloon i'm like let me pop it
yeah yeah no no i mean i mean i was the
one uh who called so
i asked for it you know
so yeah you called me bro
no yeah here's what i really want i want
you to have a holiday season where you
laugh really hard from your guts
and you get a few days off of work and
you sleeps like you're in a black hole
you wake up refreshed and you have a
breakfast that's a little bit bigger
than you should probably have and y'all
go for a walk when it's freezing cold
outside and you're miserable but it's
kind of awesome
like not worrying about mom and dad's
finances and their choices and what is
there some other way i can say it or
there's some other way i can manipulate
it or something i can do for
just set that stuff down
man yep
set it down
see what i'm saying i hate this for you
dude i really do i wish your brother
would um
have some clarity and i wish some people
in his life that were really close to
him would hold him to some high
accountability and help him get the care
that he needs
instead of
just giving him a free pass because it's
not helping him right you know that
um
we're just not there yet
but yeah if your parents are ever not
safe of course call the police um you
can get involved that way
um
you can write them the final letter you
can just be pretty open about your
boundaries or you can just let it kind
of fade right you can just let it kind
of fade and not call as much
um or not text
and just begin to work on the things you
can control which are the relationships
that uh people who are willing to uh
reciprocate right and they may reach out
in a month or two months or three months
and say hey i haven't heard from you in
a while and you can say hey it's great
to hear from you and go about your day
and um
just slowly let things fade
and if they ever call you on it you can
say yeah i've made some pretty conscious
choices to
not watch you guys get hurt anymore and
would not watch brother get
get hurt anymore because he's not
getting the care that he needs and i
just chose to step out and control what
i can control
and um man
hard hard road ahead of you and it's
also a right road
and my hope is there's some
reconciliation in your family my brother
i hope so we'll be right back
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too
i love living in a new home but i gotta
be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and they'll
try to upsell you a bunch of nonsense
that's going to hurt you down the road
and most importantly when you're making
this big life change you can actually
breathe cause you got an expert in a
team who have your back listen if you're
about to buy a home and make a big
change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple eight
loan 200. trust me that's triple eight
loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 nmls consumeraccess.org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane suite
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right we're back let's go to becky
in each town what's up becky
hey dr john thank you so much for taking
my call of course gustros what's up yes
hey well i was just calling um i'm
trying to figure out how i can get my
son to respect me
as well as control his outburst that he
has respect my authority
so tell me what's going on
well
um so me and his dad are divorced okay
um so i know that takes a toll um his
dad was very much verbally and
emotionally abusive okay towards me in
front of him okay um at the time we
lived together my son would step up in
front of me which was shocking because
he was you know little and he would be
like you can't talk to mom like that and
then now i find him now that we're
separated he talks to me
similar to the way his dad used to talk
to me that's right
sorry
so um you said i know it takes a toll
i want you to think of this as every
single thing he knows burned to the
ground
okay this isn't taking a toll
this is caustic okay this is the insides
of your little boy or on the outside now
it's that big of a trauma okay
uh and here's a devastating thing about
what you just described abusive
relationships
is especially little kids but it stays
with us until we're adults
is he knows
that part of you
is part of him
and that part of dad is part of him
and so if he identifies dad as bad or
wrong or evil that means part of him is
bad or wrong or evil
and psychologically speaking it's easier
and makes more sense especially in in a
child or a traumatized adult to identify
and to begin to reproduce the same
behaviors
than it is to distance yourself and say
that's evil and wrong and that means
part of me is dark and i gotta do some
healing inside you see what i'm saying
it's very hard for especially for an
eight-year-old so
the easy way to say it is he's got a
picture of how to treat women
he's got a picture and i'm gonna
follow that picture
until somebody do it to every woman no
because your husband probably didn't do
that to every woman it's not a gender
thing it's a you thing
okay
it's a home thing it's the way
you treat you
because he got a pretty pretty clear
model of that
uh here's a hard ques can i ask you a
couple of hard questions sure go ahead
okay not being mean i just want to get a
full picture
are you
respectable
yeah
tell me about that
look at you you're like yeah
i mean i feel like i'm a good person and
i stick true to my morals and my values
i feel like okay that's one piece
and respectable it has a a moral and a
character thing to it okay
let's pull that apart a little bit and
here's what i mean by respectable do you
have real firm boundaries
are you good with schedules and this is
when bedtime is and you will not speak
to me this way and if you've chosen to
talk to me this way then you're choosing
to leave the room right are there some
consequences too and that's what i mean
by respectable think of respectable as
i'm anchored into steel into concrete
right
are you trying
okay there so
here's that little does he live with you
full time uh yeah he does his dad every
other weekend so right now unfortunately
he's with his dad the whole month so i
know i have a lot of work to do when he
comes back
yeah so is he gonna stay with he lives
with you
he lives with me okay yeah and we just
moved out of so he had a whole new
living situation now too so it's been a
lot yeah it's a lot
um
yeah because we went from we lived with
dad and then we moved in with my parents
because i had to leave the you know that
household and you know i left and took
him with me and then separated him from
his siblings
that he has with because his dad has
other kids and then now we've moved to
our own home buyers you know our own
home
so his world is doesn't exist upside
down for the last like two years yeah
okay here's where we're gonna start okay
there's gonna be and this is gonna be a
you're playing a 20-year game now you're
not playing a week-by-week game anymore
okay okay being a 20-year game
that means you're going to have
hell on earth for us for for
weeks and sometimes months on end okay
don't fight that know that it's coming
because you got a little boy that thinks
he did something
that sent dad away forever
he thinks he did something that took
brothers and sisters away
he thinks if i just done something a
little bit different my dad wouldn't
have been so mean to mom
wait a minute
dad was mean to mom probably was mom's
fault right so he's gonna have to be
processed in this eight-year-old little
brain
right so that's where we're gonna start
we're playing a long game here here's
number two
every son knows not everyone but most
sons know their moms love them
i want you to work really hard to let
your son know that you like him
okay okay and that's hard
especially when he reminds you of your
husband when he talks to you and weighs
at your husband so you're gonna have a
lot of deprogramming to do after a month
right
when he complains about things and you
know he's kind of right you're like i
had lots of brothers and sisters and
friends and we did a bunch of stuff and
you make me do homework you're the worst
i can see that
i mean that makes sense to me
um
he had to lose everything just so you
could be safe like that math doesn't
work in an eight-year-old's
head okay
and he's gonna need you to be patient
and to love him obviously but to like
him and here's how we like our kids we
set up situations where we can
be successful
so we're going to have boundaries we're
going to firm firm boundaries we're
going to have strong anchor points and
we're going to have some silly moments
we're going to be unreasonable sometimes
hey you just want to have ice cream for
dinner yep right we're gonna do silly
things
uh i'm gonna come pick you up randomly
once every few months from school and
we're gonna go the arcade just blow up
and go to the movie
and i'm going to do this because i like
you
i value spending time with you you
aren't the reason
i left dad
he was right and this is a lifelong
journey he's gonna have to go under uh
undergo um
and then here's a couple other things
he's gonna need some real direct
counseling okay he's in play therapy
good good good good um my guess is he's
gonna have rage that would
okay make people's teeth fall out okay
um
they're gonna throw all kind of
diagnostic labels at you and all this
this is they said these adhd
of course they will and it's going to
move to oppositional defiant disorder in
the next year too right you'll you'll
get all these diagnose labels here's the
way i want you to hear those things
it's a little boy's body trying to
um respond to his world exploding
okay
so those all those labels and your son's
not broken
i know right he's not dysfunctional he
is trying to make sense of something
that it cannot be made sense out of
and he needs a mom who likes him here's
the third thing i want you to do and you
may have heard me talk about this on the
show a lot
when he gets back this summer
i want you to go to michael's or to like
uh what do you call it those home goods
stores where you can buy a big canvas
like a three foot by five foot one a big
one
and i want you to do a big painting
project together where you're gonna
paint a thing on it and then
i want you to take him to a real nice
dinner like make him dress up okay and
we're going to talk about who we are
family values
and when you're in this house because
he's going to toggle back and forth
between homes
yeah it's going to be impossible for his
little eight-year-old nine-year-old 10
year old brain to toggle that but that's
what the courts do okay
so when he's in your house this is who
we are
and let him talk into that let him
express yeah yeah
and we are in fill in the blank and some
of those things in my house are we talk
to each other with dignity and respect
we're kind to one another even when
we're upset
we're allowed to be angry but we're not
going to be disrespectful in our anger
um we pick up after ourselves we laugh a
lot
we fill in the blank right we go on
adventures we say yes we invite people
over these are some of the delony family
values they're going to be different for
you guys but here's why they're
important
for the next
15 years
they're a touchstone for you what i mean
by that when he has an outburst
and he blows up at you here's what he's
trying to find out are you gonna leave
too
is there something i can do that you'll
leave like dad did
and he needs to know absolutely not but
he can make some choices to where he
decides to leave
and he'll take ownership of that real
fast
here's what i mean uh let's say he comes
in and you say hey pick up your backpack
and he goes i don't pick up my backpack
for stupid women let's say he said
something like that
you can say get out
get out
what he knows by that
is there is a line with which mom will
weaponize our relationship and kick me
out of her presence
the other way to do that is to sit down
and look him in the eye and say
you've chosen to violate one of our
family values because in this house we
talk to each other with dignity and
respect and you chose to be
disrespectful which means you chose to
leave
my presence
you chose to leave our family table
and i want you here i like you better
than being here alone
and i breaks my heart that you i'm
choosing to have my heart broken that
you chose to leave for 10 minutes
please go do your 10 minutes and choose
to come back in here because i want you
here
you see the difference
and he is going to take quick ownership
of i get to choose when i'm in a
relationship with mom and i want to be
with mom because she likes me
so he thinks everything's like like my
fault like if he gets in trouble it's my
fault that he's in trouble absolutely
and then he goes into this well maybe i
should just die or maybe i should kill
myself or he'll throw things or he'll
like hit his head or whatever and this
is a eight-year-old boy who is trying to
make sense of
chaos
right
and he's using every word he knows every
grenade he knows it's um
it's it's the last soldier in a bunker
and everyone around him is gone and he's
gonna throw every grenade he's got
that's all he's got last last ditch
effort he's eight right
and here's what we're teaching him we're
teaching him that he can choose
because right now he's felt completely
powerless to everybody leaving in his
life
and yes he's going to blame you when he
asks dad how come you don't live with us
well because your mom walked out on me
that's how that's what he said that's
how the story right he's eight he's
gonna believe his dad he looks like his
dad he wants to be like his yeah he does
look like his dad that's right so he
sees a reflection of himself and he
didn't not like himself so it must be
your fault right so that's what i'm
saying you're playing a 20-year game the
goal isn't to get him to like you the
goal is to get him to understand that
he's likable
right that means he's gonna say
eight-year-old stuff
also if you threaten suicide you call in
everybody every time on that right you
know that
um i don't mess around with that but
when it comes to this is your fault
um you can say
i'm so sorry that you're hurting it's
not my fault but i respect your right to
be upset
i'm sad that this is the way this is too
let him know that you're a person and
that you didn't you didn't draw this one
up either right
okay and it's gonna be a long game and
he'll say things over the years that
will break your heart you gotta have
people in your life that you can talk to
as well is that fair
um
congratulations i'm proud of you for
looking in the mirror and saying he
deserves more than you deserve more than
to be abused
thank you i know that that is a grenade
that blew up everything in your life too
i'm sorry that happened
because um
it's real hard right now and you feel
like you're losing you've lost almost
everything and that you're losing your
son
um i think you did the right thing i'm
proud of you
thank you
um you have a good job you working i do
yep okay yeah putting like money is okay
you're putting it together
yeah i'm i'm fine good good good good
um
i'll walk with you as long as until i
get fired this podcast goes away
um but will you call me back if you ever
need anything
sure okay
um i'll walk alongside you the whole way
work real closely with school counselors
work real closely with school at some
point
again this is pie in the sky i'm just
dreaming here
at some point
potentially possibly
you and your ex
are able to
um he's able to not be a child
not talk bad about you
not because he's not mad and not because
he's not pouting or whatever but because
he wants his son to grow up and be whole
and be well
and
i hear that more and more these days
that people are wise enough and smart
enough and adult enough to understand
that yes our marriage was a wreck we
blew it up it didn't work i cheated i
got mad i was abusive whatever
but i'm gonna be respectful to you
moving forward as we co-parent our kid
because our kid deserves more
than repeating this nonsense
that's my hope that maybe in this
situation never gonna happen but i'm
gonna
i'm gonna hold out hope for that
thanks for call becky and i'll holla
back if you ever need anything we'll be
right back
it seems so easy but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships i'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up or you can share
hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to johndelony.com to
take the next step towards wellness
that's own your past change your future
at johndaloni.com
all right as we wrap up today's show in
honor of
what kelly puts in her coffee every
morning a band from the 90s ever clear
and the song
is called father of mine and it goes
like this
father of mine tell me where have you
been
you know i just closed my eyes my whole
world disappeared father of mine take me
back to the day when i was still your
golden boy back before you went away
i remember the blue skies walking the
block i loved it when you held me high i
loved to hear you talk you would take me
to the movie you take me to the beach
[Music]
take me to a place inside that's so hard
to reach tell me where did you go
you didn't seem to know father of mine
when you look back at your wasted life
and you don't see me i was 10 years old
doing all i could
i never understood you then and i guess
i never will you gave me a name
and then you walked away dads
show
up
we'll see you soon
[Music]